bonjour bertrand caruso bonjour à toutes
et à tous bonjour
jimmy et bonjour catherine conconne bon
j'ai enlevé trois quarts oui bonjour à
tous les éditeurs qui nous font le
plaisir voilà on va s'excuser quand même
auprès des auditeurs c'est vrai que
c'est la rentrée il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de circulation et j'étais un
peu coincé dans un embouteillage
mais l'essentiel c'est que nous soyons
là que nous puissions faire cette
interview avec vous catherine conconne
sénatrice alors on va commencer par le
carnaval parce qu'on en sort c'est vrai
c'est le début de carême mais on sait
que vous êtes une carnaval hier ont eu
l'occasion de vous voir dans des vide et
par le passé assez récemment alors de la
sénatrice que vous êtes en pleine crise
sanitaire de qu'ovide et de la
martiniquaise qui connaît les vertus de
décompression en quelque sorte des vides
et qui l'a emporté ces derniers jours on
verra bien mais je ne sais pas si c'est
la majorité des carnavaliers qui étaient
dans la rue j'ai bien vu des vidéos très
très couru mais bon je connais aussi
beaucoup de gens qui sont aussi
carnavaliers que moi qui ont joué la
prudence ils sont restés à la maison
donc vous vous avez résisté à la
tentation j'ai résisté à la tentation
c'est très dur quand on aime son
carnaval mais il faut être raisonnable
voilà j'ai choisi d'être isolé alors on
va partait peut parler de la crise
économique liée à cette pandémie
cette épidémie de covin effectivement
les les conséquences se font ressentir
de plus en plus la parlementaire que
vous êtes justement comment ressentez la
crise économique et surtout qu'est ce
que vous proposez en lien avec l'êta et
la ctm puisque on le rappelle vous est
aussi conseillère territoriale
oui bon il ya des mesures qui ont été
mises en place j'ai envie de dire tant
mieux
ne serait ce que la mesure de chômage
partiel c'est quand même soutien
important qui a pu qui a pu être porté
donc à l'entreprise menthe et nicaise
parce que pouvoir quand même payer 85 %
des salaires en temps de pandémie
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel et à mon avis ya pas
beaucoup de pays qui ont pu s'aligner
sur un tel régime donc il faut pouvoir
ça lui c'était autre chose et puis
effectivement et un certain nombre de
mesures de soutien mais j'ai envie de
dire que la crise qu vide en elle-même
ne doit pas cacher
mal être général que nous connaissons
dans la société martiniquaise
et puis ceux de voir que nous avons de
révolutionner les choses
à un moment donné je pense que les
politiques publiques telles qu'elles
sont menées aujourd'hui sont un peu
classique se ressemblent d'année en
année ressemble à du copier coller
depuis le siècle dernier
il ya peut-être à revoir un certain
nombre de choses
le coc vide peut-être locaux vides
certainement mais pas que le coc vide
mais alors le nouveau monde prônée par
le pouvoir actuel en france donc par
emmanuel macron et le gouvernement
peut-être aussi finalement est-ce que ça
a touché la ctm aussi la gestion de la
ctm comment parce que là vous avez l'air
de dire que finalement on a une gestion
classique du pays et du territoire
martinique aussi peut-être par trop
classique selon vous wii party classics
celi temps de mener cette révolution
copernicienne à la limite qui devrait en
tout cas agir en lucidité sur les
réalités de la martinique
il n'y a pas que des soutiens qu'il faut
qu'il faut attribuer je sais que c'est
une une tendance très répandue à mettre
des soutiens mais des subventions mais
il n'ya pas que ça il faut absolument ou
regarder ce pays tel qu'il est avec des
urgences qu'il s'agit de régler
aujourd'hui nous avons deux urgences
vitales qui sont là à nos portes et sur
lesquels il faut agir en toute
intelligence avec beaucoup de lucidité
la baisse démographique c'est une
urgence vitale
lorsque vous avez une économie une
martinique une population qui des quads
plus de 40000 personnes en un peu plus
de dix ans c'est une urgence parce que
cette baisse de la population agit sur
la consommation agit sur le saut sur
l'économie et agit sur la population
toute entière aujourd'hui on se
retrouvait une population qu'elle parle
importante des personnes de plus de 65
ans avec tous les enjeux que cela prouve
ô il ya aussi une deuxième urgence qui
est celle des inégalités sociales
vous avez un pays qui a fait des bonds
énormes en matière d'infrastructures on
a de l'eau potable en fait sauf accident
on a de l'eau potable on a électrifié le
pays on adhère au tournoi des écoles on
a
a énormément investi dans des
infrastructures quitté urgentes qui
était prix mondial à une certaine époque
mais on ne peut pas nier quand même
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une inégalité
sociale chélin qui kiffe la grotte et
qui crée beaucoup beaucoup de
frustration dans la population
quand vous avez 30 % de la population
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté contourner le le niveau 2 du
des prix à la martinique
les dépenses que doivent honorer les
foyers martiniquais
imaginez ce que peut supporter quelqu'un
qui touchent le smic augmente inique
avec eux c'est transpo qui tarde à se
mettre en place et qui oblige tout
chacun avant sa propre voiture qui font
que le transport est aujourd'hui le 1er
poste de dépenses des des martiniquais
je crois qu'il y a urgence à se pencher
sur ces questions vous mettez le doigt
sur la misère sociale qui parfois même
et masquer un on le sait par la dignité
de nombre de martiniquais martiniquais
on croit entendre un début de programme
presque pour les prochaines élections
territoriales qui se profile un là en
juin comment l'envisagez-vous justement
cette échéance électorale catherine
conconne à l'aune de votre départ du ppm
1 il y a à peine de quoi un an un an et
demi deux ans je sais plus son nom si
vous suivez mon actualité vous allez
voir que c'est mon obsession depuis
longtemps quand je parle de dépeuplement
d'un démon ravi j'ai mis en place un
dispositif concret pragmatique qui
aujourd'hui commence à engranger des
résultats et a crié un déclic dans la
tête de beaucoup de martinique est entre
guillemets expatriés qui se rendent
compte qu'il y a un champ de possibles à
ouvrir pour le retour au pays concernant
les injustices sociales c'est mon combat
reprenez toutes mes vidéos sénat toutes
mes interventions je me bats au
quotidien pour que ce pays soit
restituée dans ses doigts et qu'un
maximum en team qui sait pas tout est à
nouveau quelque chose que vous allez
user dont vous allez user pour les
prochaines élections mon quotidien je
crois jusqu'à présent que il faut
arrêter aussi avec les gens qui se
réveille
en veille d'élections et puis découvre
le pays tel qu'il est il y a aujourd'hui
matière agir tous les jours dans la
mener des politiques publiques dans
notre quotidien pour inscrire dans nos
gènes dans notre adn d'élus se doit au
bonheur auquel je souscris auquel j
invite tous les élus à souscrire pour
dire que le martiniquais aussi sa part
de bonheur à voir et que l'on doit tout
faire pour assurer sur ce progrès vous
appelez les élus alors est-ce que vous
avez des velléités j'insiste un peu de
constituer une liste le mois de juin
c'est quand même un peu dans votre tête
vous êtes conseillère territoriale
sortante
voilà alors maintenant comment alors que
vous avez quitté un parti puissant en
martinique
comment comptez vous vous positionnez
est ce que vous avez envie de retourner
à la ctm
moi je me serais ce que ça par exemple
aujourd'hui quand quelqu'un est en
politique je ne crois pas qu'une
élection peut le laisser indifférent
c'est on peut pas rester comme ça sur le
quai de la gare à regarder les trains
passer dans l'indifférence là c'était
mon jour d'hui c'est la fusion de deux
collectivités majeures à la martinique
qui ont qui a la responsabilité du
quotidien des martiniquais de touche son
quotidien de sa naissance à sa mort avec
des débits des urgences et des exigences
à sur lesquels il faut ouvrir donc je ne
serai pas indifférente
dans cette dans cette élection je crois
que le plus simple c'est dédié au oui ça
aurait été le plus simple de dire je
suis candidat je crois qu'il y en a qui
sont arrivés le matin puis 10
oui je suis candidat si peut-être le
plus simple mais il faut toujours avec
beaucoup de sincérité beaucoup
d'authenticité beaucoup de sérieux se
dit on est candidat pour quoi faire
on est candidat pour quoi combien quelle
quelle est la trajectoire que l'on
mettra en place pour assurer le progrès
de nos compatriotes
et c'est là que le les choses deviennent
sérieuses et qu'il s'agit de se pencher
sur un parcours qui doit effectivement
donner du sens à la pole alors c'est ce
à quoi vous travaillez certainement on
croit le comprendre entre les mots mais
les rumeurs les plus folles commencent à
courir vous concernant dix ans
effectivement que vous siégez cette
habitude vous seriez prête à aller aller
et y compris en faisant des alliances
peut-être un peu surprenante qui je n'ai
aucune alliance en cours je n'ai aucun
aucun mariage naturel ou contre nature
en cours
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé à une équipe
autour de moi de réfléchir à ce qui peut
être ce qui pourrait être le plus le
plus pertinent le plus légitime pour
assurer un avenir meilleur à 7 à cette
matinée
je crois que c'est ça l'essentiel on
parle beaucoup d'alliances beaucoup de
gens se demandent se disent on va aux
élections il se pose d'abord la question
de savoir avec qui
moi je me pose la question de savoir
pourquoi fait pour moi c'est cela
l'urgence et je crois que la meilleure
alliance et celle pour passer avec le
peuple martiniquais
alors ils viennent un appel à manifester
on va terminer là dessus catherine
conconne à le 27 prochain le 27 février
contre le traitement judiciaire du
dossier chlordécone et ses conséquences
évidemment sanitaires mais aussi
économique notamment sur le plan
agricole est ce que vous vous êtes vous
déclarez là ce matin que vous êtes prête
à rejoindre ceux qui vont aller
manifester si ça a lieu ce 27 février
prochain et puis surtout en tant que
sénatrice comment vous travaillez
notamment alors il ya le volet sanitaire
on en a vu que les liens collectifs des
ouvrières et ouvriers agricoles en poids
zone et par les pesticides parce qu'on
dit color déconne c'est les pesticides
d'une manière générale a fait et puis la
dépollution des sols là dessus alors
d'abord sur le principe de la
manifestation du 27 février contre le
traitement judiciaire
et puis ensuite ce que vous proposez
alors effectivement il ya une
manifestation populaire qui aura lieu le
peuple est tout à fait légitime à
manifester
je suis partisan que les tous les élus
martiniquais se mettent autour d'une
table et travaille à 7 après chlordécone
oui il ya un volet judiciaire qui doit
être suis je rappelle quand même que le
volet judiciaire est animé par des lois
que les parlementaires mettent en oeuvre
s'il ya une prescription qui est écrite
c'est parce qu'elle loi qui a été votée
au parlement et qui donne cette
possibilité on peut le défaire cette loi
sur lequel vous travaillez bien sûr il
peut y avoir une loi une proposition de
loi déposée par des parlementaires menti
nikkei je crois que dans la série
solutions qui sont proposées par la
commission d' enquête présidée par serge
letchimy guy ya un certain nombre de
préconisations pour que les échos side
exactement comme pour les atteintes
sexuelles série télévisée récemment
puissent bénéficier d'une
imprescriptibilité beaucoup plus longue
donc je milite pour cela il faut
travailler au fond il faut effectivement
des manifestations populaires pour que
les gens se sentent concernés que
maximum de martiniquais se rendent
compte que nous sommes effectivement
extrêmement touché par des pollutions
j'insiste par des pollutions mais il
faut aussi que nous parlementaires nous
puissions aller plus loin ouvrir ouvrir
un champ beaucoup plus optimale pour le
traitement judiciaire de ces questions
parallèlement il y à mettre en place
aussi un travail important bien
effectivement un plan chlordécone 4 on
peut dire qu'il est insuffisant dotation
financière et c'est bien mais il faut
commencer il faut y aller moi je milite
beaucoup pour que les ouvriers agricoles
soient pris en charge tout de suite soit
considéré tout de suite et qu'il y ait
enfin la publication du fameux tableau
des maladies professionnelles pour que
les ouvriers agricoles que je connais
pour certains que je fréquente puisse se
dire eh ben voilà
l'affection que j'ai aujourd'hui pour
être pris en charge à 100% par l'état
parce que nous sommes des victimes etc
autiste de victimes doit peut-être
considéré comme tel
le chantier est énorme sur ces questions
des pollutions
cela demande à tous les niveaux qu'il y
ait des applications mais que la
population effectivement soient
concernés par cette question c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'on ne peut pas non
plus avoir une société à deux vitesses
ou n'y a qu'une partie des gens qui est
qu'ils se sentent concernés par ce
problème
une dernière question quelques mots
vraiment catherine conconne je ne sais
pas si vous buvez parfois de ce rhum
réputé de la martinique on va pas citer
la marque pour ne pas faire de publicité
mais vous savez qu'il ya une étiquette
controversés ces temps derniers qui ont
donné lieu à des actions de représailles
pour ainsi dire pour alors qu'est ce que
vous dites faut changer l'étiquette faut
boycotter non
il faut cesser ces affrontements - juste
de moi je suis vraiment partisan de la
non-violence si je dis qu'il faut
absolument cesser ces affrontements la
martinique un passé douloureux une
histoire douloureuse
on a peut-être on met la poussière sous
le tapis on n'a peut-être pas affrontées
en toute heure authenticité la réalité
historique de la martinique c'est
peut-être le moment de faire peuple de
poser des problèmes de régler les
conflits mais que ça ne se passe pas par
la violence je ne suis pas du tout
partisan la violence ni des
affrontements humain c'est la violence
qu'il ya quelque chose dans une société
aujourd'hui ça se saurait merci
catherine conconne d'avoir répondu à nos
questions encore nos excuses pour ce
léger retard auprès de nos auditrices et
nos auditeurs vous retrouvez dhimmi
bonne journée bonne semaine à vous merci
beaucoup
[Musique]